oh oh it's like mattress dominoes at a
dorm where people are really going to
get injured honestly if I ran an urgent
care my eyes would be
[Music]
like the child can't help that is
physics oh no way he got clipped oh my
God spring loaded and multiple hits it
was like getting jabbed by Manny
Pacquiao or like Floyd Mayweather have
you seen that video of Floyd Mayweather
jabbing the boxing bag that's snap
listen
just a little bit of Morton's toe oh wow
that's that's a lot Happening Here
Morton's toe is a form of a Breaky
metatarsi and it's also different than
Morton's neuroma which also happens in
the feet but ironically they were named
after two different Mortons and it
obviously predisposes you to all sorts
of foot pain more likely to develop
calluses but there's like numbers where
like 30 to 40% of people have Morton's
toe and there's been all sorts of names
for it like Greek toe Greek foot
Morton's foot me and bro realizing
myocardial infarction is the same thing
as a heart
attack you know the one thing I don't
understand when someone has a myocardial
infarction we say they have a heart
attack when someone has a stroke which
is a form of basically myocardial
infarction just in the brain we don't
say brain attack can we start that can
we start saying I Had a Brain Attack
vote down below and let us know brain
attack you in or you
[Music]
out yeah honestly my left shoulder okay
it's not that I never rehab it's that I
don't rehab enough and I take breaks
from the rehab what folks don't
understand is a lot of times when they
have pain it's happening as a result of
deconditioning of major support muscles
this happens with low back pain it
happens with shoulder pain neck pain I
can't tell you the amount of times that
someone has low back pain that they
think is a disc issue when the reality
is a weak butt issue a weak glutitis
Maximus I don't know why I like saying
the Latin names of muscles makes me feel
smarter I know they're called
hemorrhoids but I feel like we missed an
opportunity to call them asteroids oh
yeah but that would sound like they're
from outer space although Uranus is in
outer space ooh
sey that's pretty
good lucky he didn't cut his foot on
that sharp rock that would have been
problematic rocking out some pretty good
push-ups with good form there too
impressive when you're wearing hospital
scrubs and you lean over to fu
everything falls out of your pockets
that's why I wear my own scrubs and not
the hospital scrubs but that's because
I'm not operating otherwise everything
just oh hey seal oh is the seal about to
fall oh isn't a seal like 550 lb looks
enormous you're awake how long have I
been asleep for 10 years wow what time
is it 6:
a.m.
honestly waking up from aoma is pretty
fatiguing imagine you have not been
sending signals to your muscles to work
and now you need them to work the
neuromuscular connection isn't there it
takes time rehab so shout out my
physical therapist occupational
therapists the people that help folks
get moving again and speech pathologists
because they not only help you learn how
to speak again but also help with
swallowing evaluations and getting
people to eat
[Music]
safely
oh
and he ate it honestly I think because
there's nothing behind that metal thing
it just made a really loud noise like a
drum I don't think there was serious
damage but wow that sucked hey Kyle it
smells like wrong dog in here what's
wrong dog everything a I wish someone
asked me what's wrong
dog this is me live looking at you and
this is me live looking at the dog
bear
hard work and dedication okay I'm going
to have a controversial opinion here it
is hard work and dedication to be
lifting weights I just don't know the
consistency of which this person's doing
it because based off their muscles I
have no idea this is likely oil
injections and this is terrible actually
the last person we've seen do these
types of injections in order to enhance
the size of their muscles ended up
losing their life it was like a huge New
York Post article about it when you
drink 2,000 Mig of caffeine because your
heart is a muscle and need to train till
failure first of all obviously no
because 2,000 migs of caffeine is five
times the maximal dose daily dose that
we say number two skeletal muscle and
cardiac muscle are not the same in fact
if I grow my bicep everyone's like dope
and I'm like cool I'm healthy but if my
heart gets bigger and it hypertrophies
that can lead to cardiac muscle failure
cardiomyopathy oh my god oh my God oh my
God what people don't understand is the
brachial arteries right there if that
gets severed she dies in
seconds and now he's going after the
femoral artery yo this this tiger knows
what's up he knows the weak points of
the human body three 2 one get
[Music]
it
oh why are these getting more and more
violent do people not care about their
well-being I mean so much could have
happened there spinal injury do we know
if that person is okay it was a
mannequin not a person oh thank God we
got him boys my we should make me wear a
heart rate monitor so you could see my
pulse go up and know that that was legit
yeah he told me to film him do this
trick there's not enough weight in the
thing I feel like it's going to flip
over oh no it did it oh that is see
people don't realize that looks not so
dangerous cuz like he didn't take a hard
hit but the fact that he twisted in that
unique way nerve compression can occur
and you can develop a spinal contusion
and it could take weeks to heal from and
you can have all sorts of symptoms
weakness nerve pain numbness tingling
sensation loss all this unique stuff be
careful if you're hungry you can smell
my Apple I can't I'm like un OIC why you
have like like diabetes or something not
diabetes is this a
joke the nails falling you not know what
OIC is oh my God that was probably the
best Kardashian impression I've seen in
a while and I don't even watch the show
but yeah the OIC Mania is real I've done
several videos on it including a long
form podcast my concern for the OIC
thing is I think about how the fast food
industry and the hyper processed food
industry has made it so that we failed
to lose weight through traditional diet
and exercise when doctors recommend it
it doesn't seem to work so then we moved
on to medication in order to help people
lose weight and then attention spans are
going to dwindle because of Tik Tok and
so forth are we going to start giving
people Aderall I don't know I feel like
we're going to be this hyperm medicated
Society I wasn't prepared for it that's
all I'll say I didn't know until I was
in my 30s hot spoons reduce the
itchiness of mosquito bites I don't know
if that necessarily Works cuz bringing
more circulation to an area where
there's already edema and swelling think
you can just burn yourself Dr Mike I'm
sure you don't approve this so
please remember just an internet
video ow oh is a hot spoon like really
hot like he's burning himself like you
just damage your skin I think I would
prefer to have a itchy mosquito bite
than a a burn because you know what most
people don't realize when you get like a
cut a scab a burn when it heals it
itches too that's why people pick at
scabs they get itchy as they heal in
fact that's a reassuring sign that your
wound is healing so this is home sweet
home for the next about 8 hours so I've
brought all my essentials um water so
I'll drink two of these every hour drink
two of these every hour sit in a first
class seat so you can extend your legs
fully and walk unobstructed with no one
else sitting near you this is an analo
so what this will do is this will
actually restructure water so when I put
it down in stir it it will restructure
that water how did we survive Millennia
without the restructuring of water I
don't think people are aware of the
words that they're using these days bone
smashing is a disturbing Trend that has
gained popularity among young people
especially teenagers who resort to
hammering down on their facial bones to
achieve a chiseled and sharp look is
that auss this practice involves
intentionally fracturing bones Lally
create more aesthetically pleasing
appearance such as bigger cheekbones but
isn't that what surgeons do like that's
what a plastic surgeon should do not on
yourself you know in Black Mirror when
they show reactions and things happening
on social media you're like that would
never happen they're just trying to
dramatize no no no folks it's happening
is it true that you have never knowingly
eaten a vegetable in your life that is
true he says it so powerfully that is
true and I guess what I've proven Chris
is that man does not need vegetables to
survive I
mean yes but there's a lot of things
that we don't need to survive unless you
want to survive optimally you are are
just one person and what may have worked
for you does not mean that that then
becomes a rule that you've
proven oh is that a bee it's one of
those bumble bees don't bumblebees don't
sting why did it go into his nostril oh
my God how did he capture that on video
that was too incredible I would get some
nasal saline as quickly as possible to
rinse that area out chemicals full of
chemical chemicals what chemicals
exactly all of just just all of them all
of them toxins toxins it the same as
chemicals where it's also just all of
them detox is that not what the kidneys
and the liver are for no just oh
supplements
right honestly a course about Wellness
is literally just saying buzzword that
flag emotions in people's minds and
they've grouped test this to see that it
works and it's very very powerful I'm
sorry do we have to join an MLM the mlms
man the multi-level marketing schemes
are so problematic they encourage you to
sell to the point where you don't even
care if it's helping people you just
want to make the sale cuz that
ultimately benefits you when it comes to
that and you're involved in that you
should really be taking a hard look at
yourself and your values and see if you
align with what you're doing Dad built a
75 ft slip and slide and attempted to
launch him self into an inflatable
pool don't go on your roofs your roofs
it's not a good idea especially as a
[Applause]
father oh my God oh my God his poor
vertebrae his pelvis his isal
tuberosities are struggling right now
wow that's a crazy stretch this is some
kind of hypermobility cuz going past
180° here is problematic because because
a potential recurrent injury unless you
work with a really good physical
therapist strength and stability and etc
etc but you are going to be predisposed
to higher rates of injury you're a med
student on rounds presenting the plan
your resident gave you and now they are
disagreeing this is a Betrayal on levels
that no one's ever seen you know what
happens all the time when I get a
patient that I spend an hour
interviewing cuz I want that to knock it
out of the park for my senior doctor
that I'm working with I'm literally
asking them questions that don't even
pertain to this illness because I want
to have a thorough history and then the
preceptor the senior doctor walks into
the room and in front of the patient I
start telling them the story and the
patient disagrees with me I'm like bro
you just told me all of this I have it
documented here and sometimes they don't
even defend you they just get more Angry
cuz they're not in a good mood cuz
they're sick and that should be
understandable but then you get thrown
into the bus and you get a bad grade now
you're ranking lower in your class you
can't get the residency spot you wanted
so you ask for a recommendation letter
they shut you down you feel like a
failure then you need to go to therapy
you spend a lot of money on therapy and
then you end up becoming a social media
influencer plugging hydroxy cut shade
throw
oh well cool down Mike cool down there's
a pole glued to this gentleman's head
and the guy looks kind of like swaggy
like he has cool glasses on like a
leathery jacket but what what am I
looking at is he in a rugula head but
what what what what why how do we just
see a clip of a gentleman saying that he
eats no vegetables with a man that says
he glues vegetables to his head wait for
it wait for it oh my God oh my like 10
ft oh my God whoa is that the same dog
after it got injured
oh yeah but that's unfair that's a
rocking chair it's not at one smooth
motion I would stop filming and help the
poor dog it's learning how to use its
limbs what's the one thing that your
optometrist doesn't want you to know
about the fact that the eyeglass and
sunglass industry is run by like two or
three major players the fact that you do
not need
glasses this is like the your dentist
didn't want you to know that brushing
your teeth is unnecessary there are
mental emotional physical and even
spiritual reasons why you may not be
seeing and I'm here to tell you that
that can be healed so when we perform
lasic surgery and we fix people's ey
highights what do you think we're doing
spiritually fixing them if a man drank
this tea for 2 weeks straight this is
what would happen he would spend money
that he didn't need to spend he would
potentially be putting unknown particles
into his body because usually what's
listed in the ingredients is not what's
actually in the thing if everyone is
healthy and at their all-time best big
Pharma companies would lose no they
wouldn't people would still get sick
because not everything is caused by
environmental causes and our body still
breaks down because of Aging if you want
to change your life into something that
you never thought was possible hit the
shop button and no don't I do not
endorse that product I say don't buy
that product at all costs in fact I
would say please don't buy that product
simply because of the recklessness of
that ad gazi it's AI it's a woozy it's a
fairy dust it doesn't exist it's never
landed it is no matter it's oh man when
I would talk to cardiologist reading uh
EKG and I be but I don't understand this
doesn't match what you're saying is not
exactly normal there's still this
irregular they like don't worry about it
because if you look at this this and
this this is the reassuring sign and I'm
like but it looks like they're having a
t but talk to the patient are they
having a heart attack do you feel like
and I'm like none of this is by textbook
you're literally doing this as you go
you figure it out as you go and then you
have to realize medicine is about
combining book knowledge with experience
with communication skills and a little
bit of artistry there's just like that
perfect little concoction rheumatologist
after ordering a million tests just to
start prism
okay this is funny but I'll explain why
it's necessary a lot of times
rheumatologists are sent patients with
very non-specific symptoms that require
broad workup part of it is ordering all
sets of autoimmune Labs based on what
the symptoms are in the patient that's
why it's important to have a good line
of communication with your primary care
doctor to see if that's warranted or is
there's something simpler that can be as
a cause of your symptoms rather than
doing that million dooll workout hey
what's up up this is a message from your
ankle I guess I really snap snap snap
when and got you laid up on your back
take a nap get the ankle WRA r r take
the time you need to rest recover and
adap I swear I'll be better girl I'm
down forever yeah we broke up but we're
getting back together speaking as a man
I plan to speaking as your ankle best
believe I understand you I want my ankle
to WP to me my ankle gets swollen from
time to the time here are some images it
hurts but it's never once wrapped to me
especially in that silky smooth voice
wow I would throw in something about
deltoid ligament or the anterior
talofibular ligament just to make it a
little bit more confusing because when
you use medical jargon It Feels Right
living 12 years in the midst of your own
waste is a problem and that was what
happened on this episode of Hoarders but
I did not like how they handled it so
click here to check out my reaction and
as always stay happy and
healthy